yes cigarette well there's not a lot of
money in it so much anymore and there is
just like there's a lot of drama a lot
of times especially because there's just
so many girls now and stuff like that
and plus time we had to porn stars on
the show they one punch the other one in
the face that's right tell me I heard
about this one Mary Jean and oh she
punch you remember name I think you
think where they go
yeah no Mary Jane has some serious
emotional intelligence issues no we like
Mary Jane don't you know they're fans an
area I think the things that make you
fight with me I mean I think I kind of
it draw you to adult or probably the
same things that make you
psychologically exotic she'll be right
they make you a good time yeah right the
same thing that would make you go [ __ ]
it you know like you're like all I did
was any debris I'm like I mean people
say oh people do porn or normal I'm like
I mean we're not normal right I mean I
don't know something told us like that's
so Kay to do for money like I don't mind
taking on a life time stigma will sit
down with that I graduated high school
of 15 I was 16 I started I was still 16
when I started college and then did that
and then so you're out of college by 20
no then I went to then I went to
graduate school okay and then touchy
subjects hey why is that subject um I
had I had some I have issues with my
with my college and sort of my college
experience
what's the issues well I mean you really
know that a compulsive I don't
understand I mean what could be the bet
what are you in trouble
well I'm not in trouble though some some
people did get in trouble there were you
mistreated after school
maybe that that might be close right oh
we can we can just then I left school
right and I was really leave with a
degree I left what we call abt which is
all but thesis all but so that's like
you do the course work on a thesis I got
an essay in poetry so not turning in
your thesis and how does that tell your
know if you don't turn in your pieces
that way well philosophically
say you didn't graduate yeah like that's
it's abt so how do you add it and then
like I guess they give you a word for it
because you did do the coursework yeah I
mean it's like a like CD like if you
yeah like if you fail to get your PhD
like if you go to the if you go in and
you do you you are your thesis and for
whatever reason they decide not to give
you the doctorate a friend of mine he's
a professor he told me what they have a
word for it which is like so that you
you do get like that like a well I mean
essentially like I don't know what you
can do with it right like you still you
you were there yeah you're there so it's
like I was there to do after school so
then I left to just be a writer I and
then in the course of doing that you
know to be a writer in in this market is
you have to do a lot of freelance work a
lot of chasing down paychecks and stuff
like that it was just pretty bleak
in terms of like being able to survive
doing it and someone was like you should
and I started writing a novel about the
French Revolution and I said I wanted to
go to Europe and backpack around and all
these friends that were doing that and
they're like you just need like a couple
grand in a backpack and like you can go
around and see everything and at that
same time there was the sight gods girls
was like 2009 so gods girls was starting
which was like a rival sight to suicide
girls and they were paying girls for
four sets and and I was like oh I could
I can do that like just take some naked
pictures and get some money I was like
just enough money to backpack around
Europe I had no idea that I would end up
doing adult for five years like this is
initially for like a thousand dollars a
year why did you almost fight with Mary
genus understand I want to she got it
was a big chase birthday I wanted it was
like last year or the year before and
the year before so it was a while I was
me and another person and we were
talking about her driving everyone knows
like she talked about her driving before
of just how horrible she is and I had
said something about no one's a good
driver who has to pay a thousand dollars
a month for insurance or something like
that we all laughed whatever went up to
big J like gave him with hug said happy
birthday and then stepped outside in
which then Mary Jean followed me and and
I couldn't tell she was angry
at me efforts because she does have a
lot of Botox and stuff so she was kind
of scaring me me me another shock and
like I died and then I tried touching
her her shoulder I'm like are you okay
like what's the matter she's like don't
touch me and she just got very angry and
she's like you're talking [ __ ] about me
you went up to Jay and talk [ __ ] about
me I'm like there was literally no
conversation in that three seconds that
I gave him a kiss on the cheek and said
happy birthday and walked outside
nothing was said about you like you're
not that important well that's another
shot right another shot okay cool yeah I
thought so
and then she just went off to like try
to pick up like a bag of garbage and
like threw it I mean she's like you're
crap you're a scrapper and I'm always
just like I'm I was like sitting next to
you just like watching like the first
time that I met her we were hanging out
at this bar and and we're waiting for
you we were waiting for her to go up and
this this girl that was clearly in some
sort of a blackout right put her fingers
in aleeah's water and like for no reason
I don't know to get some water to flick
at the bartender yeah yeah yeah she's
like zippy like lead over hovering to
dip her hands into my water to flick at
the bartender I'm just looking at her
I'm like oh you must be out of your
goddamn mind
I watched it's just like through a glass
of water in this chick's economy would
be is good doing it we did it again I
think you did it and we did it again
what are you gonna do but I want to like
almost get in fights like stop so what
happened after she threw trash out here
what happened every marriage in through
brega trashes you because she thought
you were always good and then I had one
of our friends light like Walker away
because it's like it's a comedy club
that like I host an open mic there like
one of the Booker's was there like I'm
not going to start a physical fight plus
I have framing she's in like seven inch
stilettos
what kind of training do you have well I
went oh god yeah I have training and my
dad was in Vietnam and so he taught me
like hand combat a lot of shot to
protect myself yes how to tunnel through
the backyard yeah we Hotwire cards
anything to escape from like small room
PTSD was actually very
full and some of my training so you
walked away that was dinner yeah yeah
well no and then she proceeded to like
go on Twitter unlike when reload Twitter
rampages like was texting people out
like four o'clock in the morning like
how are you friends with her she's so me
I didn't know like all I know you guys
were enemies I don't know that is enough
all of this it was just all like made up
in her mind
so first I'm hearing of this yeah I
wouldn't highlighted are in I just have
a saying I'm glad for like my narcissism
like I'm just so understand your own
balls like I don't even notice like
drama goes on around me and I'm like so
you you must have did you have a healthy
family life growing up sure I wouldn't
so how does one go from like healthy
family life graduate college graduate
high school early like the whole like
you were like a sounds like a bookworm
yeah ii think i'm tired yeah yeah hirama
to a college experience that so
controversial already i was really
driven because you know we were very
poor and i was really driven and i was
told my whole life that the only i was
going to get out of poverty was to get
an education and like i want to get
married and be dependent on a man but
you know growing up in really poor
neighborhoods i saw a lot of single mom
so I saw like that doesn't seem like a
very smart gamble so I was more just
like I was super driven I was just
terrified of always having to be poor I
just wanted like running water and like
central heating and air and like just
he's like really I just wanted to know
that like I could if I was hungry I
would have food but will not be able to
do that for myself my own weight did
[ __ ] kind of start to go crazy a little
bit I think after I was working as a TA
at University and I was like in line to
I was being groomed to be a professor
you know it's like you're going and
you're getting your your terminal degree
and you're gonna this is what you're
going to do for living is you're gonna
be professor and you're gonna write your
books and so I was doing that job now as
an ESL to do that's English as a Second
Language tutor and then I was teaching
English 1 and Composition and tutoring a
little bit in athletics and what I
started to sense was like oh this is it
like this is your life and what I saw
was a university system that was really
broken which was it was totally
exploiting people like me were being
totally underpaid were the least
qualified to teach students the most
like integral skill they were going to
need to survive college which was how to
write and I saw it that they saw exactly
my place in that system like an oarsman
in the galley ship you know what I mean
it's like and that that was never going
to change like that was just what it was
going to be and it just got really
depressed me because I I was so
sheltered I hadn't lived any of my life
and I was like I'm going right back into
a prison zone so I got a hair I got this
wild hair I was like I need to quit and
throw myself in the deep end of the pool
put myself in a situation we have to
swim out to force myself to do something
with my [ __ ] life you know yeah and so
that was the that was like it started
with the modeling and then as I did it I
was surprised how comfortable I was
being naked and being shot naked and I
was lucky I came to New York and I got
shot by George Pitts and commissioned
vaulter and Adrian Horne and all these
people that were like these sort of
American masters and that like I like it
just went really well it was it was so
easy and now you both do comedy and
that's I mean and that's part of it to
me though it's like it's kind of it's
crazy from that background to even if
you just want to rate the comedy like
that's crazy start to a life that goes
towards you know but to go for you have
to go more into comedy it's a totally
different emotion you trying to pull out
of people yeah totally different coming
yeah I can't let I can't be funny when
I'm turned on like when I'm horny I
can't laugh I'm not like I'm not good
natured but I want to commentate when I
know I had a project on stream called
show me your o face where I would just
record girls from the waist up I give
them a Hitachi and they would use to
taught you to come and I would just film
from the waist up just their orgasms yep
and the thing that I noticed because
that's those are pretty genuine organs
with regardless yes smart but Hitachi
that's like a pretty real orgasm yeah
and and when I noticed was that was when
I was shooting girls that every time
they came they laugh they would giggle
like afterwards like it was like enter
like involuntary like they couldn't and
so now when I sleep have sex with girls
I can tell if they're having roller
because if they don't giggle afterwards
they find it yeah Wow yeah I always
laughed after after I come out with me
it's like so I decide I'm gonna release
a little bit my wife always laughs in
the beginning that's insane ready to
come yeah okay good good cool yeah yep
you couldn't use the condom no when you
have to wear a condom at home No
had to had to let just know think where
we gotta do something else here because
this is what it's not happening and it
wasn't happening we did like it was just
like you couldn't keep it on now or are
like I couldn't finish
have you tried like lambskin condoms
those are actually pretty good know if
it's just to prevent pregnancy those are
actually really comfortable really yeah
I don't know I've already I've already
figured out you know we're back to
pulling out falling outside that's why
it's literally when I've never been
pregnant medically speaking it's the
best way they really is pull it out it's
the best yeah yeah sometimes you forget
good the plan because it feels good
right I'm a forgetful boy always
apologize after oh my fault
does it slip your mind sometimes it does
do you ever get the question did you
just yeah I'm sorry
whoops yeah like plan B like junior no
we have to snow no more up to you I
don't know yeah Sam look is it duane
reade down the street right when i hit
that on the way home if you want come to
you totally up on my business yeah
you're for your body i'm your your women
your body like like this that's that's
all you yeah that's good but sometimes
you just had flipped your mind
yeah you got a lot of stuff going on
really busy yeah and I'm getting older
and I forget things secret
I don't remember things as well as I
used to right and sometimes it just you
just leave it in someone has an idea oh
no for all I didn't a phone call here
from whom hello sorry hi Jim - hi Mary
Mary Jean my favorite I'm good Mary how
are you Sam I miss you so much and I'm
mr. dick I miss you too very much Mary
Jean I appreciate all you're doing it's
very good even better now that you've
asked Oh getting hoarse with me
not just yet but it will take off your
dick the same as it always is
insignificant and out of the way yeah I
just tucked up I love it when it's
talked
warm so what's up Mary Jean nothing much
I just finished getting laid I came like
time it feels so good
really you got laid this morning yeah
I've been so I've been up since like
early this morning good for you you're
productive gal Am I
I think so too I think so so Mary we
have a here's the problem
like we don't know about the drama I
don't know in the in the industry like
we're just unaware Gemini sometimes we
live in this Jim Norton and Sam Roberts
bubble and stuff goes on and and and we
realized that there's stuff happening
that we're not aware of and sometimes we
feel silly so we just want to make sure
all parties are cool because the last
thing we want to do is to is to make
anybody feel like you know they're not
brought up to speed so here's the
problem Mary Jane we we we have you know
well Lea Jeanine I don't know that
[ __ ] old ostrich who's like six years
old she can stop saying my [ __ ] name
because I've already filled me in Sam
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm trying to stay
relevant she is not a comedian she is
not a [ __ ] porn star she's not even a
[ __ ] person she is trash that's right
sitting trashing her [ __ ] space that
night outside of the comic and wherever
that comedian places that she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh I let her try to call
me or say something to my face like a
[ __ ] punch her well I know that
that's true we know that yeah you will
throw a punch but alia
[ __ ] old ass high marinus I've done
sad songs I thought and I'm going I hear
you have a brain hiring people all kinds
of your management are you still
collecting coins and pennies is that
still like a thing that you're doing
cool
did she hang out to see you angry no
she's her [ __ ] I'm still here we did
think it was funny Mary we didn't we did
think it was funny that you threw trash
at her and said you're trash so now I'm
gonna click trash
something I want to show them flowers
there is a different grade a superclass
in oh yeah classy like your [ __ ]
stretch up [ __ ]
yeah ouch yeah but it is actually I've
done more in LA and it is require
generous but only angry after New Year
and I see an MIT your phone is cutting
out Mary Jane we can't hear your phone
is cutting out hello
don't say Oh be a faithful thank you and
for you to bring up my name where is
your dog Milo's like we're still trying
to get rid of them
oh [ __ ] she brought up you know I didn't
want to stay frozen and [ __ ] like that
it yeah oh yeah right how are you guys
are you emotionally Mary Jean like how
do you really feel like inside are you
angry like daily angry are you like
really I don't think we know that is
true to just to play devil's advocate
you brought up Mary's name first
Yeah right you guys you know we well we
brought up her name just talking about
because we didn't know you guys have
ever met we just talked about student he
we're just talking about the I think the
fight I didn't know you guys had ever we
didn't rather was she didn't have a
fight I knew back him I see a trash bag
in her face externally and she did be
one who could even take off the train
big sweetheart so I would slow down on
that outfit you don't [ __ ] remember
me going to scratch bags in your [ __ ]
face more like it ha like you're playing
cornhole have you ever played that game
it's not fun I highly recommend that the
drinking game though you're not much of
a drinker obviously obviously you need
to get a life and not have a roommate at
80 or no ha yeah anyways people barely
I'm idea I hope in a DI ojala que yo are
you still talking I'm sorry I forgot sir
yeah am i talking I'm always going to be
[ __ ] talking that's obvious
well Mary we love you we just wanted to
make sure that you had your dance maker
so you her 8 year old city I live in are
real though like everything else on me
while you are literally a blow-up Oh my
office my kid yeah yeah yeah yeah ask
your point oh yeah he won't like to
receive a nod for my kids
yeah Bob when you guys run away at all
them into it like I wanna meet up
tomorrow Larry around 3:00 we pitch you
wish this white Pantages ride there
though because I know insurance thing is
kind of hard because you do suck at
driving that's the fact I usually have
exceptions and it looks like maybe you'd
be happier with your life I don't know
if we heard oh you know me so well you
know why and everything and I'm not
going to entertain this anymore
integrate club she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
she wishes because [ __ ] [ __ ] birthday
so she could [ __ ] bad a wonderful day
Mary Jean I wish you guys all anyway
yeah good for you I love you Mary wishes
right right
all right Mary Jane thank you very much
Mary Bobby sighs all right take care all
right I don't I don't
that escalated quickly